welcome to the class of 2022.
to start our online kickoff i thought
i'd take you outside
for a quick tour of some of my favorite
places at stamford
let's start at koopa you'll quickly
discover that there are several koopa
cafes on the stamford campus
the gsb one is the best it's the center
of activity on campus
and dean lowry's unofficial office
last week i was trying to keep a low
profile
but i had a chance meeting with a few
early arrivals from your class
that in my day
town square is the heart of the gsb
the tents and the outdoor furniture are
recent additions
phil knight's footsteps are a reminder
of the people who've come before you at
the gsb
and whose shoes you're filling when the
night management center was built
the artist peter wagner designed the
cornerstone
he perfectly captured the gsb
dedicated to the things that haven't
happened yet and the people
who are about to dream them up i first
came to stamford as an undergraduate
in 1990 and joined the faculty 10 years
later
i'm still amazed by the beauty of the
campus
the rodan sculpture garden is one of the
famous places on the stamford campus
and for those of you with children it's
one of the few museums that our kids
actually enjoy
some people think the koopa cafe near
green library is as good as the one at
the gsb
mistakenly i hope you all will make an
effort to experience stanford beyond the
gsb
and to meet the brilliant students and
faculty in law
medicine engineering education
sustainability and other fields
i promise it will inspire you
of course the physical campus is one
part of what makes stamford special
but it's not the important part it's the
people you will meet
and the relationships you'll form that
will truly make your time here memorable
so again welcome to the gsb we can't
wait to see what you dream up